let's see
good afternoon at Walmart we tend to
speak back to each other we're gonna
have some time in a little bit to talk
so please be thinking about what you
might want to ask us about I'm really
excited Indra that you're here
I think - they told me I couldn't come
back unless I brought you with me and I
said I'd come back only if you were
going to do it with me I want to start
with maybe the most important question
and that is when you were in your
university and you were playing cricket
what position did you play on university
you know first of all do you know what
cricket is all about I do not and I how
still it's not gonna make a difference
what I tell you I'm not really very
interested either okay go ahead what
position did you place here I opened the
batting and the bullying someone knows
what that means it's really great high
leadership high in fact I think so yeah
yeah look I was the captain of the
cricket team that was kind of my point
she's a leader I have known Indra for a
really long time and I was thinking
about what words I would use to describe
her and some of them would be visionary
competitive tough minded caring Indra
makes things happen she has a natural
leadership characteristic that you have
used not only to to lead PepsiCo and in
your previous roles but you also
influenced Walmart in a big way
appreciate it Doug but let me give you
the compliment back Doug and I know each
other for a long long time and I've
always referred to Douglas not just Doug
McMillon I've called him Doug McMillon
Walton because he represents the best of
Walmart the values of Walmart and
believe me even though we're a
generation apart in age Doug
blunder
I'm not sure much older I've learned so
much from Doug the way he operates his
large company and is repositioning and
so I think this is a two-person
back-slapping Society and I'm the
charter member of it so as we think
about what these people might be
interested in or benefit from the most
the first thing that comes to my mind is
change and I know your business well
enough and know what you're thinking
well enough to know that you're you're
facing a situation where the world is
changing very dramatically people are
changing the environment you're
operating in is changing and you're
trying to position PepsiCo for the
future so maybe we start out with
talking about you know what do you see
that that convinces you that PepsiCo
needs to change and what is it you're
trying to accomplish during your tenure
well it's so many questions Nestor than
one but let me take a shot at it I think
every company today the CEOs of every
company looking at the environment and
sort of the investor expects you expects
you to be this duck that's just sort of
swimming across the water and in the
past these Ducks would sort of furiously
swim underneath the water just to move
ahead now it's like you've got a paddle
on steroids because the pace of change
is so enormous that you've got to paddle
even faster just to make small movements
and nobody's going to give you a break
and say you can slow down or you can
actually stay in place for a while
what's changing I'll talk about the food
and beverage industry because in a way
our interest intersect there every
aspect of the business is changing what
is healthy food is changing what do
people want to eat and drink is changing
how should products be labelled
has not been defined there's no
authority that defines it supply chains
are globalizing yet traceability and
safety standards have not been
established there's an NGO in every
corner so there's somebody they're
calling us out and we don't do things
right but then there's no standard to
look at in terms of what we need to do
right the retail environment is changing
whether it's the emergence of Walmart in
the 90s and the year 2000 or now the
hard disk on
and the emergence of e-commerce
everything about the world is changing
and then right here in Silicon Valley
all of the best and brightest that we
want in our companies are being
recruited by these startups so we have a
tough time recruiting the right talent
to run our companies I speak I'm
speaking to all of you so I think what
happens is that we are facing
unprecedented change in our business
models and on top of that we have to
globalize but the world is a tough place
right now we've got economic volatility
macro economic crises in many many
places in a political upheaval so I
think companies like ours if you really
want to keep performing you've almost
got to change your model all the time
and you know Klaus Schwab of the World
Economic Forum talks about this and says
you've always got to be in beta it
sounds wonderful as a set of words but
when you actually have to practice in
the company it's pretty scary because
it's not motivating a small group of
startups or a small group of employees
who have the same thinking that you do
we have 260,000 employees and when you
decide to zag in sort of zig you've got
to tell them what you're going to be
doing why you're doing it how it's going
to impact them and why they all have to
come along with you on the journey given
let me give you examples when we decided
to change our product portfolio to go
from a predominantly fun for you product
line to including more better for your
good for your products different
profitability a very different product
line closer to agriculture change the
model in the company our employees had
they're going what is he doing why do we
have to change we're doing pretty well
selling these products why do we have to
change but the challenge of the leader
is looking around the corner and making
the change before it's too late to make
the change I remember as late as 2007 or
2008 going to see investors and they
looked at me and said why do you have to
change your portfolio we are American
we'd like soda and chips your job is to
sell more soda and chips and I sat there
and shocked because every trend that I
was seeing indicated that the
consumption of these categories was
slowing down
and I looked at the investment I said
have you changed your eating and
drinking habits and that person said
yeah but forget me I'm not the cotton
normal consumer I said the problem is
many consumers are like you they've
changed your eating and drinking habits
today that same investor says to me why
can't you go faster why is so slow
making a portfolio change it's because
people like you wear the ballast for me
you didn't let me go faster because you
always criticize what I was doing
alright but you know but that's reality
so I think we are in a world of
unprecedented change where companies the
CEOs the DNA of the company has to
change and we all have to change at a
point when short-termism abounds
everybody wants a results today and you
know the the tolerance that you have to
make the change on a large scale is not
there and I'm sure you're facing the
same issues dug and I mean I watch it in
action at Walmart so tell me a bit about
what you're going through I wanted to
ask you the questions oh I already have
enough already another one either I
think it's very similar I mean you you
know where you are and you develop a
vision for where you need to be and
trying to get from here to there is the
hard part I feel like that the vision
that we have collectively is improving
all the time but turning around and
moving an organization that's older than
50 years that was built for a certain
purpose with 2.3 million people is a big
part of the challenge and last time I
was here I admitted that I have envy for
those that were to start up because you
can write your culture on the wall or
your values on the board and you can go
that direction you get to to create
something rather than change something
and changing something feels harder and
then I said to anyone who wants a great
challenge let me know when we'll hire
you at Walmart I had one person call me
so it's you know it is hard and I think
that these people are smart enough to
figure that out but let's go to learning
mmm-hmm you mentioned that you know
you're you're seeing that what you
believe that the company should become
you didn't arrive in this position
knowing everything that you know now how
do you go about learning as an
individual and using the knowledge that
you're picking
up to shape the future because as you
know the strategic planning cycles are
gone now its strategy is being shaped
hourly not not annually I the one big
lesson I've learned Doug is that if you
just depend on the traditionalist
strategic planning cycle or dependent
standard set of consulting reports you
actually are going to do a company a big
disservice and our CEOs and leaders have
to be lifelong students and not just
students in the sense of attending
courses or reading a book or two you've
got to learn how to read widely walk the
market look at trends in the marketplace
make connections that don't seem obvious
and start to paint pictures of what the
future could be and then watch consumer
behavior I'll give you an example ten
years ago or maybe 15 years ago if you
came to PepsiCo and looked at all the
beverages that were being served on the
side tables when we're having meetings
most of the people would be consuming
full sugar beverages about ten years ago
the trend shifted I mean maybe 20 years
ago they were drinking full sugar ten
years ago they shifted to diet drinks
okay but five years ago they were
drinking more bottled water now the
point that I'd make to my guys as guys
don't you don't need to hire a
consultant to tell you where the trends
are you just have to look at our side
table remember the number of facings we
used to have a regular sugar Pepsi
versus Diet Pepsi versus bottled water
now if you're all drinking bottled water
or drinking zero calorie beverages why
do we think we are not representative of
the consumer very often I think what
happens is we separate out the consumer
out there from the consumer in us we are
the consumer and the more we can bring
the two together and say we two are
representative of the consumer outside I
think it would be better we go out and
you know our children play with other
children we see other families and when
they moderate certain products that we
sell in terms of what's given to kids
that's a trend okay so we've got to
watch all of these things and too often
I think as leaders think what
consultants tell us or what certain
reports say or certain book
say is the gospel it's really not we
have to become our own data collectors
data analyzers and then shape creators
and I think that's the toughest thing
because people who are rewriting the
rules have to create the shapes and
people don't like that because they have
a traditional model of how things work
and they hate people who have to upset
status quo and I think both of us are
upsetting status quo in a big way and
you know it's tough but it's fun it is
it's hard sometimes to take your kind of
business hat off and be a customer or a
consumer and I'll admit to when I'm when
I'm working like yesterday I went to the
Palm Springs and visited a super center
I'll put my Walmart badge in and on and
I walk into that store and I have a
certain mindset on the weekend I went
shopping because we needed milk and some
things at home and my vision of that is
over Walmart of course this
not stupid I mean but I've just
experienced out of stocks differently
everything you know felt different and
staying objective and being in the
moment something that I think I need to
continue to work on either example app
or the store I do market tours every
weekend the first few years that I was a
CEO I take pictures of what I saw in the
store and I downloaded to my people and
say there's out his talks here this
doesn't look right I mean I'd sure go on
marketers sort of about a two three-hour
radius from my home then I realized that
every division in the US had some people
waiting in the office for my emails to
respond to that quickly and I I thought
was a terrible way to run a company that
the CEOs out in the market and you've
got a SWAT team sitting in the office
waiting for the lousy photographs to
come in so I stopped sending the
photographs but I still do the market
does and I organized over it just like
you I go why is the Gatorade out of
stock when the temperature 75 degrees
and why don't we have a second delivery
or why don't we do a second delivery or
frito-lay products when we have a
holiday weekend and now I'm learning to
just agonize internally and then dump on
people Monday it's made it's tough I
gotta tell you hate stuff but you know
when you do that you really experience
your business from the consumers eyes or
the retailer's eyes because I know how
you care about others talks so when I go
to the Norwalk Walmart or look at this
shelf and I see out of stocks I feel for
you as I do for me are in stocks up by
the way yeah let's talk about design for
a minute a month or two ago we were
talking on the phone and you tried to
get me to go to Italy your milk was in
Milan Milan Design Show which I thought
was kind of a surprising invitation
don't get invited to Milan very
frequently give me a mr. great wine
tell me why did you go and why were you
thinking that I should also be there do
you know anything about the Milan design
show only what you told me on the phone
huh okay let me tell you a few years ago
we started a design capability inside
PepsiCo what do I mean by design came
and I have to tell you a little story
before I bring you into the design loop
when I first became CEO in 2006 as I
looked at our products and after that
packaging I looked at how we put things
on the shelf I thought they were
singularly alright and in some cases
unimpressive and I thought that we
needed a dash of Design Thinking in the
company so I gave all my direct reports
about 16 of them a photo album a blank
photo album and a camera and I said for
the next three months I want you to go
around taking a picture of anything that
you think constitutes design anything
could be a pencil it could be a clip it
could be a teapot anything anything you
want just fill this book for the next
three months and give me a copy so that
give it to me so that I know what what
the issues are I have to handle in terms
of design thinking here's the surprising
finding half the people didn't turn the
book in at all I have the executives the
few that turned it in a few of them had
their wives fill it in for them two
executives hired a professional designer
to fill the book in and told me they did
but the few that actually filled in the
book I still have them with me as a
memento of how bad we were it was a
horror because what they thought was
designed was not what design was so let
me now tell you what is designed to me
design is something that you embed into
a product or a service or an offering
that romance is the consumer and draws
them to the shelf or to the product or
to the service or whatever it is it's
how you think about the shape of the
product how its presented how its talked
about not just the color of the package
everything in terms of the experience
that actually draws the consumer in and
we never thought about design that way
we thought about it as is the yellow on
the Lay's bag right should we put an
extra swirl of red or should we put an
extra emoji on the Pepsi bottle so our
definition of design was very very I
hate to use the word but primitive and I
was part of that group so we all went to
design school and learned all about
design
not in terms of the package but all the
way down into design of the product
example when you eat Doritos how many of
your Doritos consumers here I love it so
you know when you eat Doritos when you
get to the bottom of the bag a typical
guy would take the Doritos bag and just
do this okay because you've you sort of
eat the crumbs that way women don't do
that women try to be very delicate
putting their hand and taking the last
Doritos but then you're leaving about
five percent of the Doritos in the bag
okay but because they're little crumbs
there which tastes awesome but in our
package design why don't we figure out a
product design for Doritos that is
completely different that a woman can
actually put in a purse so doesn't
crumple and you can actually eat it in a
more delicate way but all the way down
the last five percent I'm using Doritos
entry solving real world problems right
Doug is good stuff
Doug I got a Jenni if I solve the
problems you get more sales so it is a
real-world problem at the end of the day
I worry about one thing growing my sales
at Walmart but leaving that aside so
that's an example of how you take design
thinking all the way to the product
design itself the other is when you
think about a foodservice machine in the
past you know with the standard machines
and now with the new aspire machines we
have which are slowly rolling out you
can have almost 4 500 variants but the
machine looks like a beautiful beautiful
iPad but even more or now in an
aesthetically pleasing way and so you
bring design into a day to day
experience that was quite boring so
that's what design thinking is doing to
PepsiCo we've got amazing designers
we've hired in Milan every year they
have a design week where everything from
furniture to lighting to day-to-day
products you see the best of design from
the best designers showcased all around
Milan the whole city becomes a design a
sort of a bazaar of designs
it's just a phenomenal experience to go
there and just see what's going on in
the last few years I said three years
ago I just visited Milan for the first
time from from a design perspective two
years ago we started to build a Pepsi
design experience where we actually had
a big warehouse that we converted design
experiences with PepsiCo products so we
had an experience called the fizz looked
like a Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory
you know how do you make your own soda
with all kinds of toppings was a
fabulous experience we had Lipton pure
leaf tea how can you serve tea in an
authentic way in almost like a tea house
cafe what can you do with the gatorade
bottle the new bottle with the sensors
that athletes can now drink and it'll in
a sense your saliva and tell you exactly
what extra electrolytes need to put into
your body so we showcase some of the
stuff in a very uplifting way and what
was wonderful is the big magazines the
design magazines wrote that there were
two exhibits stood out in Milan this
year from a consumer perspective one was
Nike and the other was PepsiCo and so I
thought we'd landed was it Brady are you
missed a great one next year next year
that's a lot of progress it is I'd like
you to visit a design studio sometime
phenomenal designers we have a long ways
to go Doug a long ways to go but we're
making progress yeah I think it's going
to matter to us you know it feels like
what's happening in retail is that the
needs that customers have are being
outsourced to the Internet whether it's
mobile or voice or whatever comes next
in the future increasingly so people are
not going to have to think about staying
in stock on Pepsi yeah it's just going
to happen and we're going to play a role
in that process through our supply chain
but they leave it on to something like a
Pepsi if we keep thinking of it as the
cola that was invented in 1893 that's
like being the custodians of a utility
that's not the business we're in quistis
how do you bring excitement into this
category again and again because it's a
heritage brand
so we're doing several things whole
range of craft sodas lower sugar
offerings trying to you know make Pepsi
more of make my own beverage at home so
we're playing with Pepsi in so many ways
1893 the new Cola that we launched as a
craft soda doing very well where it is
the make my own Pepsi that's being sold
interesting consumer base is bringing in
and the lower sugar offerings of Pepsi
but the great taste will go into the
market will they all be as blockbusters
the original Pepsi probably not but they
will stem the decline of a category
while we launched all kinds of new
beverages on top so the emotional
component not just the utility sector
executive aspect of your product as
Pepsi is not a is not a drink it's an
experience it's a brand that is time
timely I would say because it defines
culture it defines sports it defines
music and I still remember a famous
music producer in California once said
to me when I ran into him he said you
know I don't have any young musical
artists that are worthy of a Pepsi
contract that's a big statement that are
worthy of a Pepsi contract because to be
associated with Pepsi that launched so
many young faces was a big thing whether
it was Michael Jackson or Britney Spears
a Madonna or Christina Aguilera and they
all made their success working with
Pepsi they were known as Pepsi stars and
so he said I don't have any young people
that are worthy of a Pepsi contract so
the Pepsi brand is absolutely associated
with culture defining moments and so we
have to figure out how to make the
product come in tune with the brand even
more as the consumer changes you can
probably pick up on some of the themes
but what happens is as companies get
older and larger they start specializing
within the business and it replicates
what you've done before so in Walmart we
have logisticians and merchants and
marketers and lawyers and everybody
specializes and you end up with these
silos that are by design in some
instances created to just keep doing
what you're doing and then disruption
happens
and you have to figure out how to take
an older company and a larger company
and change it back to being more
entrepreneurial move with speed and
change it and you can hear those themes
in interest story and it's the same in
our story and I think a lot of what
we're believing at the moment is that
we're going to help transform the
company using technology we can hire
talent we have our talent we can invest
and do a lot of that but over time what
will differentiate us and ultimately
enable us to win and have a role to play
in society is still humanity it's still
our culture it's still our people but
getting from where do we where we are
now to dare will require cultural change
in addition to advancements in
technology and that's an interesting
business challenge to take on when
you're at our scale I think the big
question for all of us does you know
there's been a lot written about you've
got to preserve the history and the
heritage of the company while you make
the change sometimes I wonder if it's a
ballast I'll tell you why because yeah
you should respect the heritage you
should respect the culture be cognizant
of where you came from but I'll speak
for myself I'd say maybe I was a little
too respectful of the heritage and
culture because what happens is when you
have companies where people are in the
company for long time and PepsiCo has
got a lot of long tenured employees
they've come into PepsiCo young they
retire from the company and then as they
leave the company they still remain
attached to the company and they are
talking about PepsiCo all the time at
some point you've got to make the break
you know what I'm talking about
they still think they're part of the
company they're running the company
right and so this book club has to be
kept happy but I don't think you should
let them run the company and in many
ways you've got to make a break with the
past because if you don't you're
spending more time appeasing the
heritage employees and their heritage
voices and supposed to saying guys we
don't have the time we have to make the
change right and guess what it's going
to be painful but the sooner we make the
change let's do it and the one thing I
learned again I'd say I was maybe a
little bit more patient
than I should have when you know you
have to make a change and people don't
come along you wait for a little while
but then after that at some point you've
got to say enough is enough you know
every third week there's going to be a
series of retirement parties you're out
because if we don't do that again the
people have been in the company 20 30
years pull you down and they create sort
of environments of saying oh the good
old days were great and people start to
believe that they're still those good
old days that could exist and they
really can't and I think if I had to do
it all over again I might have hastened
the pace of change even more seize that
opportunity to actively shape the
culture and then say you know what guys
I'm not going to sit here doing workshop
off the workshop and trying to convince
you to come along
I've tried you're either in it or you're
out and that sort of brute actions I
didn't take one of the things that gives
us a chance to make it through this
transformational period is that our
founder loved to change and while we can
respect the past you must invent the
future and our founder passed away in
1992 but the one thing I know for sure
from being around him a little bit and
from all of the the stories and
experiences is that if he were here
today he would be changing things and it
gives you that mandate you know you can
stand up in front of a group of Walmart
associates and you can say the only
thing that's constant at Walmart is and
the group will say back change and that
gives you an opportunity to say okay
let's talk about what we need to change
why we need to change and what what this
is aimed towards and if we don't we're
done it's only a matter of time you
changes carry change is very very scary
especially when you're leaving the
comfort of a large company where you
know you've had fabulous salaries
benefits pension plan that was terrific
and all of a sudden you're going to be
cast out isn't interesting it's
perceived safety it is actually the
opposite this the safety of a career of
a company the future is actually on the
change side of things not on the status
quo but if you know
that you have a role in the change you
embrace it right but if you don't know
if you have a role in the change or
because you're sure you don't have a
role because you don't have the skills
it's a problem so communication today is
different totally I joined Facebook last
week been on Instagram for a while what
do I need to be on next snapchats next
there'll be something after that
probably but you know Sam Walton was not
on Instagram or Facebook and I know I'm
a little late to the party but there's
power in it and it's it's all about
getting the word out on why are we doing
what we're doing and in what is it that
we're trying to accomplish and giving
people a voice you know communication is
not one-directional it's
multi-directional I'm just on Twitter
and I'm scared to death
cuz I have no idea what's gonna happen
look for you kids you're reckless
alright for us for our CEOs it's
terrifying because if you make one
mistake on tweeting one word out there
will be millions of people who sort of
kill you in the public domain about how
dare a CEO say what they do I'm envious
of my kids because the stuff they tweet
out and the stuff they put on Facebook
oh my god scares me to dead but you know
what this is the great thing about being
young what they don't know yet is all of
that is going to follow them for the
rest of their lives well your that's it
duck fat dog you know you and I don't
have anything to worry about
hey I want to ask you a question how do
you manage to be CEO of Walmart living
in the small town where every move that
you make is tracked all the time what do
you mean
tracked you mean everybody knows
everybody like Mayberry is something
like that little bit bigger than
Mayberry yes yeah we live in a cool
place that's actually changing a lot but
it's still small it is it's a bubble
it's not like the rest of the world in
some ways and so it's really important
for us as leaders to be out we travel a
lot we're all over the world but go back
to this really small place where if you
go to the Walmart which I do everybody's
like hey Doug how you doing people
follow you around the store to make sure
everything was in stock you know
so we have to be cognizant of the bubble
and not let it cause us to be
comfortable it's not the most
competitive market in the world
that's very true you know what I go and
market to us it's the same thing they
set up the market for me so I always see
the perfect execution so now when I go
to any city and they say oh we're going
to the following three streets to do a
market or I go guess what I'm going to
decide where we're going and now they're
terrified because I could pick a place
that's completely off the beaten path
and I don't want to see a prepared
market I want to see the market as it
exists normally for the consumer that's
one we don't tell stores we're coming
when we write yesterday or not popped in
to the store when associate told me once
Doug you're just like the queen of
England and I said in what way and I
said everywhere you go you smell fresh
paint that's a good one you got to
remember that right you got to remember
that and stay real I think we got time
maybe one more subject in me and the one
I'd like to pick is making a difference
in the world
so you've ended up in this position
probably growing up as a kid you knew
I'm going to be the CEO of PepsiCo I
mean you probably knew that but now you
find yourself here and you have this
responsibility and this platform really
to try and make a positive difference in
the world how do you think about that
and how do you help lead the board and
your management team towards making that
difference and what's it mean to you
personally you know that I'm the more I
delved into this whole area of making a
different sustainability I'm convinced
that unless you feel it unless you feel
it deep down in your heart and you
really understand it you'll be doing the
service to the whole area of
sustainability in my case I grew up in
Madras in India where had those days and
even today I think there's there wasn't
much water in the city and we had so
little water to live on every day that
this whole notion of water availability
and water use was a crisis for me all my
life I didn't know a time when water was
a plenty until I came to the United
States okay
so water was seared into my head the
second is we grew up eating and drinking
a certain way and all of a sudden I
realized that as you look around the
world you see look around all of the
health issues around the world food
played a very important role in people's
health and wellness so you know one had
to worry about that aspect too and then
my daughter went to work for the
Environmental Defense Fund EDF and I got
a whole new appreciation for all of the
environmental issues beyond water
whether it was a carbon footprint
whether it was fisheries whether it was
any issue she would actually show me all
of the statistics what it was doing to
the world overfishing in certain coasts
or plastic and oceans and when you start
to really feel these issues and think
about your kids and their kids you ask
yourself what is my role as a steward of
a large company to make a difference in
the world through this incredible
platform that I have called leader
leader of a big company that could
either contribute to the issues or help
alleviate the issues I knew that I
didn't want to contribute to the issues
I had to start helping the issues and to
the extent that society had changed and
I was perceived as contributing to some
of the issues I had to make a change to
my business model Darrin was born our
notion of performance of purpose which
is how can we keep performing while
changing the portfolio while
fundamentally changing our environmental
footprint and then the third one which
is really the one that I'm most excited
about is what can we do for our
employees so that they can come to work
at PepsiCo feeling like PepsiCo is a
place where you can not just make a
living but have a life so that you can
bring your whole self to work the
company treats you in a fair and
equitable way provides you the support
system to be who you are to allow you to
be who you are and we embrace you
completely and so performance of purpose
is not a corporate social responsibility
program it is not it is how we make
money because our belief is if we don't
change the portfolio we can't keep
delivering performance
if we don't change our environmental
practices we won't get a license from
society to operate and our cost goes up
because we pay for water we'll end up
paying more for plastic recycling so we
have to do that and if we don't get the
best and brightest in terms of people we
won't be able to deliver performance so
performance at purpose is how we make
money not how we spend the money we make
which is what corporate social
responsibility is all about so that's
really what we're all about
very well said we see the same way I
feel the same way we want to open it up
for questions fire a difficult one to
enter if you could to start us off if
the first question comes from Twitter
it's actually to you both and it's a
classic and what organization and what
leader do you most admire and why need
time to think I got to be around Sam
Walton a little bit Sam was the founder
of Walmart he's the first person that
comes to mind there are a lot of
positive characteristics there that
we're still trying to live up to today
in terms of who I admire at the moment
rather than one person I think I would
characterize a group of people one of
the awesome things about what we get to
do is we get to meet a lot of leaders
and what comes to mind is that there are
people out there that are genuinely
taking risk to try and make the world a
better place
and this would be a very logical time to
play it safe be a very logical time to
try and stay off the radar screen but
sometimes you got to step out there and
you've got to put some personal equity
on the line and try to change something
and there are people that are doing that
some of the CEOs that live in this part
of the world are doing things like that
to try and and improve the world and I
admire that
I'm going to give you two one is you
know something that sounds tested and
tried when I became CEO I call Steve
Jobs and I said I'd like to spend a
little bit of time with you and just to
sort of understand what it is to run a
company the way you've changed it and he
graciously agreed to spend some time
with me and he gave me two or three
hours I think of his time and some of
the lessons he taught me about design
how do you take something that you truly
believe in
and stick with it as opposed to changing
your point of view because the outside
world wants you to change your point of
view were phenomenal lessons that he was
so gracious to give me the time and that
he gave me those lessons I'll never
forget I think the world lost an
incredible person in him he did tell me
a few things like don't be too nice when
you really don't get what you want and
you really believe that's the right
thing for the company it's okay to throw
a temper tantrum throw things around you
will you know people will talk about it
and they'll know it's important for you
and I think that itself was a valuable
lesson in terms of I honestly believe
that in terms of people I admire I tell
you the people have begun to really
admire these days are people who head up
these NGOs because they don't make much
money in fact they barely make ends meet
but yet they feel so deeply committed to
a cause they do the research they go
visit companies in their headquarters
they'll do goofy things but you know
what it's goofy if you look at it
strictly from the point of view of their
bugging me but if you look at it through
their eyes you know walk a mile in their
shoes you have to be proud that they
feel so strongly that they want to make
the world a better place so all of these
people who run NGOs even though one side
of me says god I wish they didn't have
such a big megaphone the other side of
me is so proud of what they do and I
think we're all going to change and
become better companies because of their
leadership who would like to go next
how about right here hi my name is NAR
doulos and I'm an MBA - here my question
for you was you mentioned international
growth before and I'd love to hear how
PepsiCo and Walmart are thinking about
the African market specifically in the
mid and long term what do you think
you're going to have to do differently
to win the consumers there you know I
tell you PepsiCo and Africa doesn't have
as big a footprint as we would like to
have but I think it's an actually wide
open market in so many ways and I'll
tell you why
the African consumer is you know the
economic plight of the African consumers
improving enormously so that's a very
good thing
second the continent is
angry for the right supply chains the
right products to come in so I think the
market is just now sort of taking off I
wish we'd been there earlier but now
that we are you know increasing our
footprint there I think the challenge we
have is how do we go into Africa with
healthy products right off the bat and
not start with the fun for you product
start with more the good for you
products the more grains fruit and
vegetable stuff that contributes to the
nutritional quality of the African
consumer which means we have to set up
the agricultural supply chains which is
really what we're working on right now
so I think especially the sub-sahara
Africa region because in parts of Africa
like Tanzania or South Africa Nigeria in
already but the rest of Africa I think
we're working on setting up the
agriculture supply chains and there's a
lot of it available in Africa we think
the potential is huge I'm really excited
about sub-saharan Africa and personally
was involved in the investment that we
made there a few years ago and what I
believe is the best management team on
the continent the best management team
in Africa from a retail point of view we
have various store formats we're going
to end up with an important business in
Nigeria someday in Kenya in South Africa
where most of the businesses now and
we're today in about 12 different
markets there and personally I've been
to five or six different countries in
the region in the last few years and I
feel an energy and an optimism and an
opportunity that I believe will be a
very good business for us over time we
want to be local we decided not to buy a
hundred percent of the business because
we wanted others to be able to benefit
from the business that we were growing
there we're sourcing locally to the
extent possible which is not that hard
because most of its food and we're not
moving at a great distance anyway so I
think there's an opportunity to grow
there for a long period of time and
reach a lot of people and fulfill our
purpose which is to save people money
and help them live better but we're
going to have to generation skip in some
ways with technology I'm sure know how
advanced mobile is and how advanced some
things like payment are in some parts of
sub share in Africa and so just like the
rest of the world we've got to be on the
front edge as it relates to technology
and do it in an African
way I'm very excited about it hi my name
is Ben I'm an MBA - first of all thanks
so much for coming so you talked about
having to be a bit conservative or the
pressure to be conservative as the the
CEO of a big company if because I've
done Twitter you have to be you know
conservative with your investors so
having to innovate to succeed in this
fast changing world how do you resist
those pressures and what what can CEOs
like you do to resist those pressures I
think personal conservatism versus
taking risks with the business are two
different issues so with innovation
you've got to write the rules for you
know our products because very often if
you really want advantage you've got to
be the first mover so I think on a
product side and the product experience
side we can take as many risks as we
want when I was talking of conservatism
I was talking about personal messages
going out or messages that we put out on
behalf of the company we've just got to
be careful by putting our personal
messages I tell you something on
innovation the bolder we can be the
better the more we can break the rules
the better off you're going to be
because you know the world is full of
ideas today and if we don't do it
somebody else is going to do it in fact
I'd say little startups are capturing a
lot of the growth today even in our
space even in the food and beverage
space so in many ways in our company we
have to act as if we are a bunch of
little startups that's what we are a
bunch of little startups so in order to
do that we've got to allow people to be
bold you know write the rules any way
they want and that's what they're doing
in our company when we have twenty two
billion dollar brands and now we've got
another three or four in the pipeline
each of them is a little startup and
they're not conservative at all Pepsi is
not a conservative brand as an
individual I am I'm sure the next year's
going to be less conservative than me
but I am a conservative person because
I'm terrified of all of you you know
I think the advice I would give you
whether you're going to start a business
or you're going to join a business would
relate to values and pausing for a
little bit of time to know who you are
and what you stand for in our case at
Walmart we have four core values we
respect the individual we strive for
excellence we serve the customer and we
act with integrity those four core
values resonate for me personally so
it's been quite easy to be part of
Walmart because those are the things
that I personally believe in and the
reason that matters in the context of
your question is lots of things are
going to come your way they're going to
there's going to be an emergency
tomorrow something's going to come up
and I'm going to have to deal with it or
when when you're in these jobs you're
going to have to deal with it and you
need some sort of a foundation to stand
upon and pausing to remember what are
our values my personal values and how
does how does my response here relate in
that context if you don't have that
foundation you're going to be moving
around trying to figure out one instance
at a time what to do whether it's a
question about risk-taking or how you
handle a crisis or something else so it
sounds a little bit hokey I supposed to
pause and write down or think about you
know what you want your end story to be
but I think it's valuable you know
pretend that you're at your retirement
celebration some day what do you want
them to say about you
what legacy do you want to have left and
predetermined before you start that
that's going to be your outcome yeah I'm
not sure who's deciding who goes next I
go for it yep thanks for just sharing um
I have a question so Amazon is a huge
competitor like if you were who's that
Amazon Amazon got it I mean it if both
of you could talk to Basil's now what
would you say to him and go on vacation
Jeff doesn't need any money but I'd be
happy to pay for his vacation they are
doing such a good job and as a retailer
and somebody who grew up serving
customers I admire the innovation and
the solutions they're bringing to
customers and I'm challenged by it and
and part of our culture is to embrace
what competition is doing and learn from
it and try to move quickly to adopt what
we should adopt within our own company
in some cases that's dangerous because
it can look like following and be
following and if you're following
somebody you're only ever going to be
second best so you have to at the same
time be who you are and innovate within
the context of who you are but clearly
what they and other e-commerce companies
mobile commerce companies are teaching
us is that technology can be used to
solve customer problems in a different
way and it saves them time it makes life
simple and easy and we did that for a
period of time in one way and now we've
got to do it in new ways so you know I
welcome the challenge I like a
competition the one thing that I know
for sure is that customers are going to
win and they will decide who's here and
who's not here and thankfully for us we
don't compete against just one company
we compete against a lot of companies
and what matters the most is how much
we're improving and getting better so I
like it gets me up in the morning and I
feel challenged and I and I wouldn't
want it any other way you said it all
thanks for coming and sharing my name is
Erin Chen I'm from China
and now MBA one so I have a question for
both of you is more personal personal
career like development so wine for dock
like Doug you have spending all your
career life in Walmart but actually for
now in hours years it's not very common
so I really want to know what drives you
to stay with one organization for a
whole life and another question is for
Andrea like you have tried a different
kind ro and different kind of industry I
want to know when you decide to when you
find your passion and how you get this
passion for it Thanks you know um
I think I've learned from all the
industries I've been in because it's
range from you know when I was a
consultant you learn everything from
chemicals to banking to high-tech
healthcare I did everything so I was
fantastic to learn strategy through the
eyes of a BCG because you know you
realize that strategy is not industry
specific it's frameworks and how you
think about a business I learned that
and then through my journey that
Motorola and ABB and then coming to
PepsiCo you know just going from high
tech to utilities and power plants again
I learned so many different facets of
business when I came to PepsiCo even
though I hadn't really worked in the
consumer space I could think differently
at that point when I joined PepsiCo
PepsiCo needed new thinking so I came in
and started to shake up status quo from
day one and PepsiCo gave me the leeway
to go ahead and you know make all the
changes and suggest all the changes that
need to be made and I think why I've
stayed in PepsiCo and why I've put down
roots and PepsiCo from the day I joined
the company and this is one part of the
culture that has not changed
I feel like PepsiCo is my company it's
embraced me and now I make sure we
embrace other employees I feel it's my
company it's not some public company
called PepsiCo it's my company every
aspect of the company I feel I can
change it anytime I want I felt that way
when as head of strategy I felt that way
when I was CFO when I was president I
feel that even more so as a CEO I mean
you have that sense of ownership about
the company why would you leave
something that you own and so I've put
down roots and I don't regret for a
moment that 22 years that I've been at
PepsiCo and it's the greatest ride of my
life whether I was CEO or not is
irrelevant it's been the greatest ride
of my life my dad was a dentist and
dentistry is hard none of you are going
to be dentists right that's why you're
here he was a dentist for 40 years and
it is hard you get up every day you go
to see people who don't really want to
see you they're there because they need
to be and so I was I was influenced in a
big way to try and create a career for
myself that was flat
Cybil because I didn't want to be
trapped trained for one job and have to
do that job forever if I didn't like it
so I went for a business degree I went
for my MBA and my MBA was primarily
driven so that if I got into a situation
where I wasn't happy I could change jobs
I thought it would help me move but then
I ended up working at Walmart and I
really started because I just needed a
summer job to make money for school and
I loved it and that's why I'm still here
I have had a blast I have gotten to do
more than a dozen different jobs I've
worked across countries across formats
we deal with everything from you know
marketing to logistics to finance to
legal to Africa how fun is that
so when I'm not having any fun anymore I
won't do this anymore but for more than
25 years now it's been a blast and I've
come to care about it an awful lot and I
have been bored if I was bored I'd go do
something else or if I were working
around people I didn't like I'd leave
but there are a lot of great people
around where I work thank you very much
for coming
Oh my name is Sarah foo and I'm a second
year MBA student and I'm told I they're
lucky got the last question so my
question to you is so obviously you talk
about a lot of like changes and taking
risk but a lot of that like it's only
going to be measured or seen or
evaluated over years but also today if
you look around the world like the
investors or just the market in general
is like very short-sighted and then
there's like so much noise in the market
so how do you balance is like short-term
demand for you to like deliver versus
the long term vision to take risk and
make like long term djent that are
actually good for the business that's
really well said I think you get it
should be how what do we do about it
what do we do about it you know I tell
you something I think you got to look at
the investments you make in the company
as a portfolio there's a bunch of stuff
that delivers in the short term and that
gives you the breathing room in the
fodder to invest in the long term
because I don't think especially in our
industries that are more established
unlike a start-up I don't think you can
say look wait for three or five years in
five years you start seeing you
nobody is going to believe you because
we are expected to deliver because we
established you know legacy companies so
the way it is I look at things in Pepsi
goes I know what we need to invest in
constantly balancing projects that will
deliver today countries that were
delivered today which can then provide
the ammunition for us to invest in
long-term initiatives you can't have too
many long-term initiatives or too many
short-term initiatives because you don't
want to spoil the investor with too many
short-term invests you know programs
that then don't give you the permission
to invest for the long term so this
judicious balance is what we worry about
all the time and that's what and you
know I think tell you the only way you
can do that is if you have the support
of your board of directors for public
companies the board has to completely
buy into your program and back you in
case investors say we don't like the
shape of your delivery um if we ran
these businesses for one quarter of one
year we would harm them greatly and we
care too much about them to do that but
as we're articulating that long-term
vision which you know in some cases may
be beyond one investment cycle we have
to communicate clearly what our strategy
is and be held accountable to milestones
along the way so it's not enough to say
I'm managing this business for the long
term get back to me in five years we'll
see how it goes we'd like to try that so
I think as long as you are deliberate
thoughtful you build relationships and
communicate whether it's the investment
community or your board you can do it in
our case we have a family that owns
almost half the business so it helps a
lot if they believe in what you're doing
it helps us have a long-term perspective
not just a perspective that's I don't
have a right here I don't have that
pathway to ever get the chance again
please join me